I'm sorry that was really hard for me
you guys like I wanted so hard uh just
to like scream every time fetterman
spoke because he wasn't saying things
and this is the important point about
fetterman and Biden is it my job to
translate for you what he's saying what
what
baleen he said baleen like yo we make
fun of true nashaba to pressure better
calf care next fluorescent Etc et cetera
yo he's got I think like 15 new words in
that at least and it's no it's the
representative's job to translate your
feelings into policy it's not your job
to translate the representative I like
to make up new words but this is on
another level even far beyond the
machine it's the party of the machine
and they put people forward because the
people the candidate doesn't matter it's
the machine that's behind them yeah
that's absolutely true the big money
behind it gigander says am I the only
one to find the Dr Oz and medically
disabled fetterman debate ironic
you know uh I will say this because we
we have a bunch of stuff we can talk
about I want to talk about Kanye for
sure
this was
Dr Oz I think he did he did a decent job
um I was surprised he actually answered
some of these questions fetterman didn't
seem to understand what was going on no
no joke it's not just that he he needs
the machine so you'll notice there were
two monitors
one was transcribing and one was delayed
transcribing probably because if he has
to like look back and forth if he misses
something
but how many times has Oz got to say
like I'm not going to cut Social
Security and then Federman goes who's
going to cut Social Security it's almost
like he couldn't understand what was
being said when Oz was like I'm going to
digitize portions of our education
system and get rid of the administrative
staff bloat and then Federal's like you
didn't even answer the question he's
like I did I said I'm gonna and like you
repeated the answer that was just as
dead I don't know if there's enough
words to describe or an effective word
to describe how painful that was they
clearly coached fetterman he had some
canned lines that he put in there he had
practiced saying Roe v weighed like four
thousand times so he had you know they
gave him some coaching and then thought
they could let him loose but it just
didn't work what's what's up with him
saying words the same way every time bro
v wait
because I I support wrote v Wade and I
I'm for rope wait it was almost like you
ever listen to those automatic voice
things where it's like hello you have
reached and it's because the word was
recorded one time and then the program
splicing together so it like doesn't
that's what it sounded like
that to me was nuts what we were
watching right there is the Republicans
winning the Senate I gotta say I don't
I'm not a huge fan of doctor I mean I
don't hate him I think he got my vote if
I had to vote in that election man uh
laser focused compared to the other
option we've been making fun of Dr Oz I
think he's he's a bit goofy but here I
just watched two guys and you know you
guys ever watched that Family Guy
episode where they hire an ugly chick to
stand next to Meg this is a fan so
because so by comparison she looks more
attractive that's exactly what that was
I thought Dr Oz was bad I'm sitting here
thinking to myself Kathy Barnett could
be there running circles and then Dr us
he didn't even do bad he had some good
answers his closing statement not bad
not bad
um his talk about college I think
college is dumb but talking about like
you said digitizing elements and getting
the the below from the administrative
staff I'm like I actually like that and
then federman's like you didn't even say
anything and it's like whoa dude when
fed look normally in politics Donald
Trump let's say you got Trump and Biden
or something or know Biden's not a good
example because he's very similar but
let's say you've got like you know guy a
guy guy B
one guy might say like I'm going to
lower gas prices by doing a tax holiday
the other guy says you're not even
proposing a real plan to lower prices
that's an argument right because you can
argue that a tax holiday is not
permanent and then everyone argues when
fetterman says you didn't answer it it
just sounds like he's unable to
comprehend what's being said next to him
but I want to warn everybody we're all
saying like I just said we're watching
the Republicans win the Senate you know
they voted for Biden they voted for
Biden despite Trinity pressure and all
that stuff actually he may have said
that after the campaign or whatever but
the point is we all knew Biden was
hiding in the basement we knew he wasn't
going to campaign and maybe that's why
maybe the Democrats knew that if Biden
went out and actually tried to debate
more than a few times or campaign it
would be endless commercials of
gibberish garbled nonsense and that's
why they don't have him do it he kept
calling a lid and hiding I was wondering
if that was like the technique if they
make people feel bad for him literally
feel so bad for him like oh well we'll
just give it to him I don't know I
wasn't asking to see if you think that
was even like a thing they would try I
have no idea but like I said you know I
just looked it up half a you know a
quarter of a billion dollars rather in
this race 250 million dollars do you
know there's ten thousand people pulling
this you know you know all sorts of
consultants and they've come out with
they think they can win this they
obviously think that they can win this
and after this I don't know but I'm just
they think he's the way to go I'm
imagining some like
campaign PR guy who's like sitting in
the office smoking a cigar and he goes
fetterman and they're like what are you
kidding they just had a stroke is like
trust me yeah and then it's like this
radical plan where he's like this city
slicker salesman he's like people are
going to want to vote for the guy who
can't talk straight you're mad we're
gonna lose this and then they're gonna
pull out a victory somehow wouldn't be
surprised they did that joke I don't
remember what it was but when Bush was
George W Bush was president I remember
seeing some comedy skits where the joke
was he's folksy and an idiot in public
fetterman and then behind the scenes
he's like Mr Burns or some like
ridiculous intelligence well the the gag
we brought a couple times is that like
Joe Biden's on stage he got lost
recently he's like where are we going
and then as soon as he walks behind the
curtain he stands up straight and goes
all right
let's get back to work ladies and
gentlemen
did they believe it they believed it sir
good
if people actually thought I was of
sound mind I'd be going down with Hunter
Biden at the same time what if there was
like a pollster being like Oh a lot of
people are getting Strokes nowadays
that's relatable that's the best in this
guy and again a quarter billion dollars
that's a lot of money that we're talking
about here and again if you invest that
much you think you're gonna let someone
quit halfway no that's money down the
drain so I think you know this poor guy
is being pushed out there obviously when
you have a mental uh injury when you
when you have a severe brain injury you
need to rest you need to take it easy
you shouldn't be on on a debate stage
what New York Times is calling the most
watched debate of this political season
wow this is this is not okay and it's
not good to watch I felt uncomfortable
watching it and this is truly a
disservice not only to the people of
Pennsylvania but the people of the
United States I want to believe
I want to believe that come tomorrow
come The Day After Tomorrow When the
polls roll in the polling is going to
flip ah this is going to take the lead
and with the with the all already bias
in the polling system we're going to be
looking at Oz winning again I find Oz a
little bit goofy but hey better than
feminine for a lot of reasons I want to
believe it but come on guys they voted
for Biden isn't there a strong
possibility people watch that and said
don't know don't care well the thing is
people really didn't like Trump that's
what Biden had his Ace in the Hole and
people don't really dislike Oz they
might you know have some issues here and
there with them but let Trump evoked the
ire in humans I think like and no one
come before that I've ever seen I think
the reason Trump may have endorsed eyes
because people do like him and his
attitude was like look Oz is a celebrity
he's a people person he's a people
pleaser and we're we're politicos so we
are like Kathy Barnett was the right
option but Trump I mean Trump knows his
stuff he's probably thinking PR wise
you've got a famous TV doctor or Kathy
Barnett who we respect more but she's
very much hyper political take policy
out of it think of what a normal person
who doesn't know anything about politics
thinks after seeing this there's a guy I
respect him he's polished he's clearly
articulate he's got a med degree you
know I've seen him on TV yeah that's him
okay he's fine
then there's another guy he looks like a
bub I feel a little bad for him he
shouldn't be up there no of course he
shouldn't be up there do you think they
put fetterman on the on stage right
because of his neck if they if they put
fetterman stage left the camera angle
would have showed shown the massive
growth or whatever he's got on his neck
yeah they control and micromanage almost
every aspect of this debate uh the
questions that are specifically asked
are a lot of times random sometimes
they're leaked to the candidate just
like we saw with Donna Brazil and
Hillary Clinton but when it comes to the
stage the breaks the time everything is
negotiated between the two candidates so
it wouldn't surprise me if fetterman
said and his campaign said hey we want
to be on this side of the stage and you
know they they debate that all the time
and they negotiate someone someone super
chatted sobik mentioned that if
fetterman wins he's going to step down
for health reasons and then give
assuming Shapiro wins the governorship
an appointment
yeah wow that's what it'll be
interesting someone totally
uncharismatic like a very very dark
person wow we couldn't win I'd love yeah
yeah
some kind of Ruthless corporate Banker
head literally is just seething to just
suck the blood out of the poor working
class Blue Collar people of Pennsylvania
just like most politicians but but
they're literally gonna appoint mumia
mumia I don't know who that is never
mind it's a big Philly thing he shot he
shot a cop never mind
and there was a big controversy with
Snapple and and that as well yeah that's
a big case mumia Abu Jamal yes political
activist uh yeah that way they did in
New York that what they did in New York
I was just listening and I do not want
to start making fun of John fetterman
having a post-stroke hard time talking
but that what they did in New York even
Oz started to mesh his words because
he's sitting next to fetterman like in
that state of mind it's crazy but that's
what they did in New York with Kathy
hokel they just put her in position of
power yeah and she's horrible could you
imagine if someone here was unable to
speak or understand and we thought we
would keep doing the show I'm sorry guys
like I I've had days where my like I I
was losing my voice so I'm like can't do
the show yeah they got to take show
comes first and the country comes first
the job comes first right but but I mean
like well you know what I'm saying is
like your health does I'm not going to
try and do a Showtime like this you know
what I mean is if someone can't do the
show you got to put the show first and
take them out they can't be part of it
because they're going to ruin the
process and yeah federmen should not be
here I mean look imagine he's standing
next to he's in the Senate and he's
standing next to an uh McConnell or
somebody and they quickly come up and
say John you got to understand what
we're pushing this bill because it
matters the most that we get inflation
done right now so we got it we got to
cut spending here we gotta cut spending
here we're looking at 2.3 increase you
need to get on board with this I'm not
going to ask you twice and John goes
what he's going to be a terror to work
with I would hate to be a staffer do you
think that when they're on when they're
when they're debating and negotiating in
in a senate floor they're going to be
having a big machine so that when
someone walks up to him personally and
says I need you to back me on this one a
Democrat even Democrats need to consider
this for themselves a democrat's going
to walk up and say John vote Yes we need
to get this bill done he's gonna go
I I believe
you know and then they're like great and
then it's gonna come and he's gonna go
no and they're gonna be like what is he
it's like well you supported him dude
but no that's why I think he'll step
down John press wrong button yeah so if
he were to win he would immediately step
down that's that's something I mean that
sounds reasonable because there's no way
this guy can function in this job this
is insane it would drive all of his
compatriots in saying all the Democrats
would be hate the guy they would loathe
looking at him when he walked in because
what a mockery is making of American
Juda of Law and Order or political
system like uh it's amazing that the
people even had the patience to put him
on TV like that I know it's going to
happen tomorrow because I know it's
already happening right now
across this great nation there are many
a meme Smith sitting at their computers
clipping away and producing mashups
songs Auto Tunes
it's just going to be insane tomorrow
because when you when you have this guy
remember when he he said recently he was
like send me to Washington so why for a
PO to push work for work and you're like
what did he just say bro I'm sorry man
I'm not trying to be mean but the dude
didn't say words I mean he said words
but they don't go together
imagine which got an hour of that an
hour fairly inquiry is going to say he
he did great though they're going to
translate for him yeah this is what they
do for Joe Biden Joe Biden will be like
you know inflation It's gotta because
it's too high and good you know we're
gonna work and it'll make it you know
down and then the news report the paper
will say like Joe Biden said that
inflation was too high and that we need
to get it reduced immediately with
ellipses no they won't even put a quote
they'll be like Joe Biden would Express
outrage over High inflation costs and
promise to get the price down when is
when his quote is bad enough where he
says like come on man and like the
prices you know very high those ellipses
in a little bit Biden said quote you
know the prices are too high dot we got
to get them down but if it's too much
gibberish they're I'm willing to bet
this tomorrow a bunch of the papers all
Democrat supporting aren't going to
quote him directly they're going to say
in response to a question from Oz
fetterman expressed X Y and Z he that
exactly I have a counter Viewpoint I I
think he this is again just speculation
here is going to win is going to become
one of the biggest politicians out there
and I think there's going to be a Biden
fetterman 2024 ticket that's going to
absolutely take it because what better
opportunity for multinational
corporations than to of course embed
people in candidates that actually don't
know what's going on that could just
rubber stamp all of their policies which
happens right now according to my own
personal opinion with the Biden
Administration I think it's clear as day
he's not in charge here the people who
put him in charge they're the one
calling the shots here they're the ones
pushing the great reset they're the ones
building back better they're the ones
destroying the American economy and of
course stopping domestic energy
exploration and production which is
deliberately creating an energy crisis
right the uh the campaign slogan for
Biden fetterman 2024 is going to be like
bertafon forgive come on you know Shabba
and people are going to be like what
it's funny but it's true I mean like a
lot of people study how white houses are
structured and with Trump I mean if he
had something had happened to him you
know everything would have been chaos
because everything went up to the top it
was very personal with Biden you know
you've got all these little czars you've
got Ron Klein Gina McCarthy podesta in
there as well podesta if Biden goes away
the machine continues to Clack because
it he doesn't matter if that's the same
with Spiderman he doesn't matter I wanna
I'm sorry I just need to stress this
before we wrap up this you know segment
I want you all to realize where we are
as a nation
we're at a point where one of the oldest
and most prominent political parties has
decided to run someone with a severe
mental disability restricting their
ability to comprehend words that are
said before them
we can make a little bit more crass
we are at the point where the Democrats
are running
and have run and won with brain damaged
candidates I'm not saying that to dig at
fetterman I'm not using brain damage as
a kind of insult it is a fact Joe Biden
I believe had an aneurysm and he got
metal plates put in his brain he
struggles to speak fetterman recently
within the past what was it five months
ago had a stroke I feel bad I do not
wish that on anybody
you gotta know when to bow out but here
we are in America
this is the point where this nation is a
man with a severe mental disability just
on a debate stage for an hour and and
there are there are prominent media and
activists who are acting like this is
good and okay and the right person to
vote for they may as well may have well
in my opinion conceded the race
immediately to Oz and I do not
understand what they're hoping to gain
out of this
oh geez I hope people can see reality I
really do I I don't know how distortive
I know drugs can really mess people up
perception wise and you don't see things
that are happening sometimes food also
I'm afraid can do that but I hope to God
people see that that debate and see it
for what it was
there was a really funny moment where he
just said I just believe when she was
like how are you going to get cost out I
just believe and it's like that sums up
the Democrat position a lot of things
yeah and also randomly yelling and
screaming yeah doesn't really make you
look strong no thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there